Kita semua perlukan kemampuan untuk menyampaikan maklumat peribadi tanpa takut sesiapa menguping. Tapi mereka bentuk
sistem yang kedap untuk ini bukanlah mudah. Dalam episod hari ini Qiskit di bilik darjah kita akan bercakap tentang bagaimana
sesuatu yang dipanggil pengedaran kunci quantum boleh
membantu. Selamat kembali ke Qiskit di bilik darjah. Dalam siri ini kita akan liputi topik yang mungkin korang jumpa dalam kursus universiti berkaitan pengiraan quantum. Setiap video disertai modul interaktif yang dipautkan dalam deskripsi jadi
pastikan korang tengok. Hari ini kita akan menjelajah alam kriptografi quantum. Kriptografi adalah kajian
teknik komunikasi selamat. Ini amat penting untuk banyak bahagian dalam kehidupan kita. Setiap kali korang guna
kata laluan untuk log masuk ke laman web hantar pembayaran digital atau bila kerajaan menghantar perisikan ketenteraan semuanya dilakukan
melalui protokol kriptografi tertentu supaya orang yang menguping tidak boleh mengetahui rahsia kita. Tapi ada ketegangan di sini. Macam mana
kita memastikan bahawa orang yang ingin kita komunikasi boleh memahami mesej kita tapi orang lain tak boleh?
Sepanjang sejarah ahli kriptografi telah mencipta banyak protokol berbeza untuk cuba menjadikan mesej mereka seimmun mungkin
daripada penguping. Kadang-kadang dua pihak yang nak berkomunikasi secara selamat bersetuju atas sesuatu
kod terlebih dahulu yang diharapkan begitu rumit sehingga penguping tidak akan dapat memecahkannya. Tapi seperti
yang ditunjukkan oleh orang seperti Alan Turing dan pemecah kod zaman perang lain walaupun kod yang paling rumit boleh
dipecahkan. Idealnya kita nak hantar mesej yang disulitkan sedemikian rupa supaya tidak ada corak
dan tiada cara penguping boleh faham tanpa juga memiliki kunci rawak rahsia yang hanya pengirim dan
penerima yang tahu. Tapi kemudian kita terdedah kepada kelemahan baru. Macam mana kita boleh hantar kunci ini dan pastikan
tiada sesiapa yang memintas? Pada tahun 1984 Charles Bennett dan Jill Brassard mencipta
kaedah untuk menghantar kunci dengan selamat menggunakan bit quantum yang kini dipanggil BB84. Ciri utama bit quantum
atau Qubit yang membolehkan protokol ini adalah bahawa ia mematuhi prinsip ketidakpastian. Korang tak boleh ukur
sistem quantum tanpa mengganggunya. Hari ini kita akan mulakan dengan contoh kod kriptografi mudah. Kemudian saya akan
tunjukkan bagaimana pengedaran kunci quantum dan prinsip ketidakpastian boleh membolehkan kita guna penyulitan yang hampir tidak boleh dipecahkan.
Saya akan lalui protokol BB84 secara terperinci dan akhirnya kita akan jalankannya pada komputer quantum sebenar.
Saya akan walk through protokol BB84 dengan terperinci dan akhirnya kita akan jalankannya pada komputer quantum sebenar.
Pertama jom mulakan dengan permainan yang korang mungkin pernah jumpa sebelum ini dipanggil cryptogram.
Korang diberi urutan huruf yang kelihatan rawak tapi dengan menggunakan pengetahuan korang tentang corak dalam bahasa Inggeris
korang boleh gantikan satu huruf dengan yang lain untuk memahami mesej itu. Inilah contohnya. Ini adalah mesej
rahsia dengan sifer penggantian mudah. Jadi semua R mewakili satu huruf M mewakili huruf lain
dan sebagainya. Kalau korang nak cuba selesaikannya sendiri hentikan video sekarang.
Rupanya mesej ini disulitkan menggunakan sifer yang sangat mudah yang dipanggil sifer Caesar di mana
abjad hanya digeser dengan nombor tertentu dalam kes ini 9. Jadi A menjadi J B
menjadi K C menjadi L dan seterusnya. Semakin panjang mesej semakin mudah untuk
melihat coraknya. Jadi dengan mesej sepanjang yang kita ada sifer Caesar atau mana-mana sifer lain yang hanya
menggantikan satu huruf dalam abjad dengan huruf lain cukup mudah untuk dipecahkan. Cara yang lebih selamat untuk mengkod mesej rahsia
adalah dengan apa yang dipanggil pad sekali pakai. Dengan pad sekali pakai korang boleh ada anjakan berbeza untuk setiap huruf dalam
mesej. Korang hanya perlu beritahu rakan korang apakah anjakan pada setiap satu supaya mereka boleh dekod mesej itu.
Senarai anjakan ini dipanggil kunci atau pad. Ia dipanggil pad sekali pakai kerana ia digunakan sekali kemudian dibuang.
Kalau ia digunakan lebih dari itu corak akan muncul yang boleh menjadikan penyulitan boleh dipecahkan. Dengan penyulitan pad sekali pakai
kedua-dua mesej yang disulitkan dan kunci secara individu hanyalah rentetan omong kosong rawak. Tapi
bila korang gabungkan keduanya korang akan nampak mesej rahsia muncul dari bunyi hingar.
Jom buat contoh ringkas. Katakan saya dah cipta dan hantar kepada rakan saya pad sekali pakai ini yang biasanya ditulis dalam
binari. Dan kemudian saya nak hantar mesej I love quantum. Kemudian saya akan enkod mesej itu
menggunakan pad sekali pakai seperti ini. Pertama kita tukar huruf dalam mesej kita kepada binari. Setiap huruf A hingga Z akan
sepadan dengan nombor 1 hingga 26 yang ditulis dalam binari. Jadi A akan menjadi 0 0
0 1 B 0 0 1
0 C 0 0 1 1 dan seterusnya.
Dan ruang akan menjadi semua sifar sahaja.
Kemudian inilah yang menjadi mesejnya. Kita enkod mesej dengan menjalankan XOR antara setiap bit dalam mesej dan
bit yang sepadan dalam pad sekali pakai. Kalau korang tak pernah nampak XOR sebelum ini ia
bermaksud exclusive or. XOR antara dua bit akan menjadi satu kalau hanya satu
daripada bit itu adalah satu dan sifar kalau kedua-duanya sama ada sifar atau keduanya satu. Jadi set pertama lima bit dalam mesej yang enkod
menjadi 1 0
0 1 1. Saya akan tinggalkan selebihnya XOR untuk korang buat sendiri. Tapi intinya adalah
mesej ini kini hanyalah rentetan sifar dan satu yang rawak tanpa corak. Ia sama sekali tidak dapat difahami oleh sesiapa yang
tak mempunyai pad sekali pakai yang kita guna untuk menyulitkan mesej. Jadi apa yang kita dah pelajari setakat ini? Beberapa skim penyulitan
lebih baik daripada yang lain dan ada yang boleh disimpulkan oleh orang bijak yang mencari corak dalam mesej yang disulitkan
Tapi kunci yang benar-benar rawak yang menggeser setiap huruf dalam mesej rahsia dengan jumlah rawak yang berbeza tidak boleh
disimpulkan kerana tidak ada corak dalam mesej. Satu-satunya kelemahan dalam skim seperti ini adalah memastikan
kunci yang digunakan untuk menyulitkan mesej tidak jatuh ke tangan yang salah. Di sinilah pengedaran kunci quantum
masuk. Dengan menggunakan Qubit Bennett dan Brassard mencipta cara bagi dua pihak untuk bersetuju atas kunci dan
cukup yakin bahawa pihak ketiga tidak mendengar secara diam-diam. Protokol BB84 ini sedikit rumit tapi
kita akan lalui langkah demi langkah. Untuk penjelasan ini jom bawa balik rakan lama kita Alice dan
WEBVTT
Bob. Protokol dimulakan dengan Alice menyediakan set Qubit untuk dihantar kepada Bob. Qubit ini mengandungi
maklumat yang akan menjadi pad sekali pakai atau kunci dikongsi mereka. Alice mula-mula menjana dua urutan rawak yang
sama panjangnya. Satu adalah urutan rawak sifar dan satu dan yang lain adalah urutan rawak x dan z yang mewakili
asas di mana dia akan menyediakan Qubit. Kemudian dia akan menyediakan setiap Qubit dalam keadaan quantum mengikut
gabungan asas dan nilai bit yang ditunjukkan dalam carta ini. Jadi kalau bit adalah sifar dan asas adalah z dia akan
sediakan Qubit dalam keadaan sifar. atau kalau bit adalah satu dan asas adalah X dia akan sediakan dalam keadaan minus. Kalau
korang tak pasti tentang asas dan keadaan quantum ini tak apa. Perkara utama yang perlu korang tahu adalah
bahawa pengukuran dalam setiap asas hanya mempunyai dua hasil yang mungkin. 0 atau satu untuk asas-Z dan plus atau minus untuk asas
X. Kalau korang ukur keadaan sifar dalam asas-Z korang akan sentiasa mendapat sifar.
Tapi kalau korang ukur keadaan yang sama dalam asas x korang akan mendapat hasil rawak sama ada plus atau minus masing-masing dengan 50%
peluang. Jadi Alice mungkin menyediakan rentetan Qubit seperti ini di mana ini adalah rentetan rawak
sifar dan satu dan ini adalah rentetan rawak x dan z. Jadi elemen pertama dalam setiap daripada dua
urutan adalah 0 dan x. Jadi itu bermakna dia akan menyediakan Qubit pertama dalam keadaan plus dan seterusnya.
Setelah menyediakan semua keadaan Qubit Alice akan hantar kepada Bob Qubit-Qubit ini dan Bob akan pilih secara rawak antara X
dan Z sebagai asas di mana untuk mengukur setiap satu. Jadi kita kini tambahkan beberapa baris pada
carta untuk mewakili pilihan dan pengukuran Bob. Jadi inilah pengukuran
Bob dan pilihan asas. Dan inilah hasil pengukuran Qubit yang dihantar Alice kepadanya. Akhirnya Bob
boleh tukar setiap pengukuran kepada bit menggunakan jadual yang sama yang Alice guna untuk menyediakan Qubit. Bila dia mengukur
keadaan sifar atau plus dia tetapkan nilai bit sifar. Dan di mana dia mengukur keadaan satu atau minus dia letak
satu. Jadi rentetan bit akhir Bob adalah baris terakhir ini.
Perhatikan bahawa bila asas langkah penyediaan Alice dan langkah pengukuran Bob sepadan maka bit mereka akan sepadan
juga. Tapi kalau Alice memilih untuk menyediakan Z dan Bob mengukur dalam X atau sebaliknya
maka bit yang sepadan Alice dan Bob tidak semestinya sama. Jadi cara mereka boleh bersetuju atas rentetan bit
untuk pad sekali pakai mereka adalah dengan menelepon satu sama lain dan memberitahu satu sama lain asas mana yang mereka guna untuk setiap Qubit.
Bila asas sepadan mereka simpan bit dan bila tak sepadan mereka buang.
Jadi dalam kes ini Alice dan Bob akan bersetuju atas rentetan bit 0 0 1 0
0. Bagaimana skim ini melindungi terhadap penguping yang tidak disedari? Jom tengok apa yang berlaku bila penguping seperti itu
bernama Eve memintas Qubit yang dihantar Alice kepada Bob. Dia tidak tahu dalam keadaan apa Qubit-Qubit ini atau macam mana
Alice menyediakannya. Jadi berkat prinsip ketidakpastian dan sesuatu yang dipanggil teorem tidak boleh klon dia tidak boleh
buat salinan identik Qubit untuk dihantar kepada Bob. Kalau dia boleh maka dia akan dapat
menguping tanpa pengesanan. Sebaliknya dia meneka asas untuk mengukur setiap Qubit mengukurnya dan kemudian
menyediakan set Qubit palsus baru untuk dihantar kepada Bob. Ada cara lain yang lebih tersembunyi yang Eve boleh cuba untuk
mengetahui tentang Qubit tapi tiada satupun yang mengatasi prinsip ketidakpastian.
Jadi kita hanya anggap kaedah penyadapan langsung Eve ini. Inilah carta yang menggambarkan
penyediaan Alice pemintasan Eve dan pengukuran akhir Bob. Jadi kini bila
Alice dan Bob bercakap di telefon untuk membandingkan asas mereka mereka akan memutuskan untuk menyimpan bit ini untuk kunci mereka tapi
bit tidak sepadan. Ini kerana Bob mengukur Qubit yang disediakan Eve bukan Qubit asal yang Alice ada.
Kalau mereka bandingkan subset bit dalam rentetan bit mereka antara satu sama lain mereka akan nampak ada yang tidak sepadan dan
anggap pasti ada penguping. Jadi kerana Eve ditemui Alice dan Bob akan buang
rentetan bit mereka dan mulakan protokol semula. Tapi kalau Eve tidak mendengar dan subset
bit yang Alice dan Bob bandingkan sepadan maka mereka boleh teruskan menggunakan bit yang tinggal yang tidak mereka
bandingkan sebagai kunci dikongsi. Setelah Alice dan Bob mempunyai kunci dikongsi Alice boleh hantar mesej yang disulitkan kepada Bob dan
Bob adalah satu-satunya yang boleh mendekripnya menggunakan kunci itu. Setelah kita lalui protokolnya jom cuba pada komputer
quantum. Ada beberapa perkara yang perlu diingat untuk eksperimen ini. Pertama
BB84 hanya benar-benar berguna kalau Alice dan Bob jauh dari satu sama lain. Untuk eksperimen yang kita akan buat Alice
dan Bob berada pada cip quantum yang sama. Jadi eksperimen ini tidak akan berguna untuk bertukar maklumat peribadi tapi ia
masih merupakan demonstrasi konseptual yang baik bagi BB84.
Kedua komputer quantum sebenar mempunyai bunyi hingar. Jadi walaupun asas penyediaan Alice sepadan dengan asas pengukuran Bob
dan tiada penguping masih ada kemungkinan kecil mereka akan ukur bit berbeza disebabkan ralat dalam
komputer quantum. Bila mereka membandingkan rentetan bit mereka untuk menyemak penguping mereka perlu ada beberapa toleransi untuk ralat sebelum mereka
membuat kesimpulan bahawa penguping pasti telah mengganggu dan mereka membuang keseluruhan kunci. Sekarang dengan
amaran itu jom mulakan dengan eksperimen tanpa penguping. Pertama kita secara rawak
jana tiga rentetan bit berbeza masing-masing dengan 20 bit. Yang pertama adalah rentetan bit awal Alice.
Yang kedua adalah senarai asas di mana Alice akan menyediakan Qubit.
Di sini kita pilih sifar untuk mewakili asas Z dan satu untuk mewakili asas X. Senarai terakhir adalah asas di mana
Bob akan mengukur setiap Qubit. Berdasarkan tiga senarai itu kita boleh buat gambar rajah circuit dengan arahan untuk
penyediaan Alice dan pengukuran Bob. Semua Qubit bermula dalam keadaan sifar. Jadi untuk menyediakan Qubit dalam
asas Z Alice sama ada tidak buat apa-apa untuk keadaan sifar atau menerapkan gate NOT atau X yang ditunjukkan sebagai kotak biru berlabel X
untuk keadaan satu. Untuk menyediakan dalam asas X dia menerapkan sama ada gate Hadamard yang mengambil sifar kepada keadaan plus
atau gate NOT diikuti oleh Hadamard untuk menyediakan keadaan minus. Kemudian dia hantar Qubit kepada Bob. Set kotak seterusnya
dalam circuit mewakili pengukuran Bob. Untuk mengukur dalam asas Z dia tidak perlu menerapkan gate lagi.
WEBVTT
Dia hanya mengukur yang ditunjukkan oleh kotak kelabu ini. Untuk mengukur dalam asas X dia mula-mula menerapkan Hadamard dan
kemudian dia mengukur. Kita akan jalankan circuit ini menggunakan sampler primitive Qiskit runtime. Dan outputnya adalah rentetan bit
pengukuran Bob. Kemudian kita boleh bandingkan rentetan bit Bob dengan rentetan bit awal Alice dengan membuang bit
yang asas mereka tidak sepadan. Dan kita nampak mereka berdua mendapat kunci yang sama.
Ingat ini adalah perkakasan sebenar jadi sesekali mungkin ada bit yang patut sepadan tapi tak. Dalam kes ini semua
bit sepadan tapi kalau korang jalankan ini semula sendiri korang mungkin mendapat ralat tapi selagi kesetiaan hampir satu
Alice dan Bob boleh cukup yakin bahawa tidak ada penguping. Sekarang jom tengok apa yang berlaku kalau Eve memintas
Qubit. Kini kita ada dua circuit. Yang pertama menunjukkan penyediaan Alice dan pemintasan serta pengukuran Eve.
Yang seterusnya menunjukkan penyediaan Qubit palsu Eve dan pengukuran Bob. Kita
boleh jalankan circuit ini seperti sebelumnya kemudian tengok apa yang Alice dan Bob dapat bila mereka bandingkan rentetan bit
mereka. Kali ini mereka mendapat kesetiaan 0.6 berulang. Ini jauh lebih rendah daripada
yang boleh dijelaskan oleh bunyi hingar dalam komputer quantum. Jadi mereka membuat kesimpulan bahawa Eve sedang menguping. Pengiraan quantum adalah
terkenal dan sering digembar-gemburkan kerana potensinya untuk menyelesaikan masalah yang sukar. Tapi komunikasi quantum dan kriptografi
sering mendapat perhatian yang jauh lebih sedikit walaupun potensi yang quantum boleh tawarkan dalam bidang ini adalah sama rata
penting dan menarik. Hari ini kita bincangkan protokol yang paling awal ditemui untuk pengedaran kunci quantum yang merupakan
secara praktikal kebal terhadap penyadapan yang tidak diketahui. Kalau korang nak cuba menghantar kod yang tidak boleh dipecahkan dengan
kunci yang disahkan secara quantum pergi ke modul yang dipautkan dalam deskripsi.
Terima kasih kerana menonton dan jumpa korang kali berikutnya.